is a 45 year old high school custodian
and part-time Barber who just earned his
high school diploma I saw this story pop
up 45 year old Elmo de Silva this was
reported by Atlanta news first he's
custodian for the Indian Creek
Elementary School in Clarkston and he
just joined over 40 other adults who got
their High School diplomas during a
recent ceremony he said it wasn't easy
it was a struggle for a while and to
achieve and get through it and looking
back I'm very proud this guy had to drop
out of high school to take care of his
younger brothers now all these years
later he's gone back gotten his high
school diploma I think it's great big
congratulations to that guy and the
political lesson to take and the
personal lesson for all of us is it's a
reminder that it is never too late to
improve yourself